nostalgia critic as one of a billion
people who have recommended this I
challenge you to the ice bucket
challenge my god so it's come to this
the ice bucket challenge are you really
so desperate for views will you really
submit yourself to something that's just
a map but it's a van for a good cause
raising awareness for ALS something
people should know more about but it's
so corny everybody's doing it will it
even be relevant by the time I do it
what would it be like a little over a
week old that's like 10 years in at that
time would it be easier just to donate
the money instead of course you're
donating the money dumbass that's what
they all do but doesn't that kind of go
against what the challenge is it
directly goes against what the challenge
is it makes no fucking sense but it
makes no fucking sense for a good cause
so do the ice bucket challenge make a
donation and know that you have done the
equivalent of the Harlem shake for the
good of humanity the Harlem shake is
never for the good of humanity
well this one is make it and and
critical it is your destiny I have
nothing to say on this one I just like
turning my
matically as I do from this angle enough
procrastinating it's time to raise
awareness for ALS it's time to do the
ice bucket challenge
hmm that's good early 90s white failure